the latest events in the Jujutsu Kaizen
story have set the internet on fire and
the entire fandom is in disarray some
are satisfied many are extremely angry
but everyone is shocked about what
happened and how it all went down like
seriously even if you predicted that
something like this could happen
eventually you still didn't think that
it would happen the way that it did it
was so crazy that I saw accounts on
social media that normally don't even
cover Jujutsu Kaizen straight up
spoiling what happened way before the
official translation even came out
people just collectively lost their
minds over Gojo but with the official
translation finally out we need to
correct some important misconceptions
about Gojo's death and we need to
discuss the potential that we're all
missing something yes things look
extremely bad for Gojo he looks
extremely dead but could this be a
massive case of debating by the author
of Jujutsu Kaizen are there any
scenarios in which Gojo could still
survive or come back to life well yes
yes there are and we will break them all
down right now in this video we will
also talk about what happens next if
Gojo really is dead for good so let's
get into it you guys know how this works
if you enjoy our Jujutsu Kaizen content
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment right now
for that YouTube algorithm and if you
want to help us become a special grade
anime YouTube channel by hitting 2
million subscribers don't forget to
subscribe right now subscribing on
YouTube is completely free but it helps
me out a lot so when the leaks for
chapter 236 first came out there was a
part where Gojo mentioned someone's
father and at first we were speculating
that he might be referring to his own
father however it seems that he was
actually referring to megumi's Father
toji fushiguro Gojo was basically saying
that he wanted to tell me about toji
himself but thankfully he told shoko to
fill megumi in in case something
happened to him I mean that's cool and
all but I think me has bigger problems
right about now anyway let's start off
with the scenario that Gojo really did
just die in jjk and that he isn't coming
back this is definitely possible I mean
if anyone was ever going to kill Gojo it
would be the strongest sorcerer in
history sukuna and besides if Gojo just
keeps defeating everyone in the series
then the other characters like Yuji will
never get a chance to grow however there
is a difference between killing off an
important Mentor character in order to
pave the way for the next generation and
suddenly killing that character off
screen with the most Whiplash I've ever
seen between two chapters of a manga
chapter 235 ended with kusakabe
declaring Gojo to be the winner of the
fight and then chapter 236 begins with
Gojo seemingly already dead after being
killed off-screen we didn't even get to
see what happened I've seen a lot of
people complaining about this and I
think that's valid especially if this
really does turn out to be the end of
Gojo in the story to be fair I've also
seen people saying that this chapter was
actually brilliant and again if this is
the last we ever see of Gojo in the
story I have to hard disagree on that
taste is of course subjective but you
can't tell me that so much Whiplash and
killing off one of your most important
and most popular characters suddenly off
screen is good writing it just isn't it
ends up being extremely unsatisfying and
anti-climactic for the reader now once
again this is only true if we assume
that gegege will simply leave it at this
and won't expand on Gojo's death or
won't bring him back in any way frankly
I don't even see how the story
progresses from here if Gojo is
completely gone because we know that
sukuna still has a trump card Gojo even
confirmed that sukuna didn't go all out
so if he already took down the strongest
Sorcerer of the modern era Gojo who
could possibly defeat him now and then
there's kenjaku and his whole plan with
Master tangit how can these villains be
stopped now without some sort of major
ass pull by the heroes to be clear I'm
not saying that Gojo dying is itself an
some people people are saying
that but I think that his death at the
hands of sukuna is believable and the
way that it was explained makes sense
although it is a bit out of pocket
mahuraga was able to change the nature
of its own cursed energy in order to cut
through the fabric of space itself
allowing it to cut through Gojo's
Infinity Gojo's Infinity protects him by
infinitely dividing the space between
Gojo and his attacker essentially
creating a paradox in which the attack
will slowly move closer to Gojo but it
will never actually reach him by cutting
the fabric of space itself maharaga is
able to just cut through Infinity like
it wasn't even there after seeing
mahoraga use this technique against Gojo
run in front of him suguna figured out
how to use it himself and he eventually
copied it in order to kill Gojo yes it's
sudden and a bit out of pocket like this
is a serious escalation in terms of
power creep but it isn't completely
unrealistic within the world of jjk but
again after this law long epic battle
and everything we've seen from Gojo if
he was to die then he deserved an epic
final scene full of emotion and
intensity he deserved better than to be
killed off-screen so maybe we are
missing something and maybe get plans to
bring Gojo back in some way after all
Gojo practically died in his fight
against toji but he came back from
death's door now of course he is injured
even more severely now but we can't
forget that Gojo can physically alter
and rewire his own brain so who knows
what kind of new power or ability
related to reverse curse technique he
could potentially come up with and
somehow regenerate maybe Gojo was just
at death's door again but he will find
some new insane power-up that will allow
him to leave his Fallen comrades back at
that airport between life and death
while he returns to this world if that
happens it will again anger a bunch of
people because they will call it plot
armor but Shonen is full of such
power-ups and such fake out deaths so we
can't rule it out there are also
scenarios in which Gojo's body really
does die physically but Gojo's Soul
survives in some way we always have to
remember that Gojo possesses two
incredibly rare and overpowered
abilities Limitless and the six eyes
someone like kenjaku would do pretty
much anything to gain access to such
powers and I could totally see him
appearing on the battlefield and trying
to take over Gojo's body right about now
yes he'll have to figure out some way to
fix Gojo's severe injuries but I
wouldn't put that ability past him after
all kanjaku can literally place his own
brain inside a body that is already dead
and then reanimate it and bring it back
to life and use it for his own ends and
this includes the body's cursed energy
and innate techniques kenjaku may try to
invade Gojo's body repair it in some
Frankenstein way and then take Limitless
and the six eyes for himself this could
potentially make Kendrick will worthy
opponent even for sukuna creating a
rivalry between the two like yeah
they're both villains but at the end of
the day they both have their own
interests and agendas so this could lead
them to clash but if kenjaku ends up
controlling Gojo's body then it's no
longer Gojo in there so he's still dead
right technically yes but we still know
very little about how Souls actually
work in Jujutsu Kaizen although we do
know that they are a real thing that
exists in that world could Gojo's Soul
somehow remain attached to his body
after Kendrick moves in and then
eventually Take Back Control once
kanjaku repairs the body like could Gojo
somehow alter his brain or some other
part of his body to keep his soul
Tethered to his body even after death
it's not impossible because again there
is still a lot of room to play with when
it comes to the nature of a soul in jjk
but there's also another option in
chapter 222 we saw Yuji training martial
arts with kusakabe from their brief
training Scene It is clear that for some
reason Yuji so all is inside kusakabi's
body and Kusa cabezol is inside yuji's
body this wasn't really explained so it
raised a ton of questions of course but
the most popular theory is that now that
he's free of sukuna Yuji finally managed
to develop his own unique innate
technique and it seems that this
technique may give Yuji the ability to
switch Souls with other people or
perhaps manipulate souls in general and
the switching is just one aspect of his
power if that's the case then maybe Yuji
has the ability to save Gojo by secretly
transferring his soul into another body
maybe even yuji's own body so they can
share it temporarily then if kenjaku
ends up possessing Gojo's body and
repairing it Yuji can just return Gojo's
Soul into his body at a later date and
Gojo can then take back control from
kenjaku this is obviously a heavily
speculative scenario but based on that
Soul swapping tease from chapter 222
clearly wants us to know that some sort
of soul-swapping shenanigans may be
happening in the near future okay but is
there a scenario in which Gojo could
come back to his own body without any
Soul swapping stuff after sustaining
such a severe injury in chapter 236 we
did see Gojo in that Purgatory airport
waving goodbye to his deceased comrades
and then seemingly leaving on an
airplane so what did that mean did it
mean that he's just moving on to the
afterlife or did it mean that he's
actually moving on to something else
entirely could Gojo being as incredibly
strong as he is push himself to evolve
Beyond Humanity kind of like master
tengin master tengen was a powerful
Jujutsu sorcerer during the NADA period
of Japanese history so about 1200 years
ago and the master was known for
spreading Buddhism in Japan as well as
forming the foundation for Jutsu
Sorcerers initially tengan was just one
person a woman but eventually tengen
merged with other humans also known as
star plasma vessels in order to avoid
losing touch with humanity and becoming
a threat to the world that's because
tengen's innate technique makes the
master Immortal but tengen still needs
to merge with a new vessel every 500
years at this point in the story Tangen
has advanced Beyond mere humanity and
has a body that doesn't even look human
anymore right now tengen is said to be
closer to a cursed Spirit than a human I
can't help but think that the reason why
tangen's Evolution Beyond Humanity had
such a strong focus in Gojo's backstory
is because it was foreshadowing Gojo's
own ultimate fate just like tengen
during the NADA period Gojo is one of
the strongest jujusu Sorcerers in
history and the strongest pillar of
modern Jujutsu sorcery not only that but
Buddhism and spreading Buddhism is a key
characteristic of most of the powerful
ancient Sorcerers including of course
tenge and Gojo himself is full of
references to Buddhism his very name
satoru is a reference to Satori a Zen
Buddhist term used to describe the
sudden experience of Enlightenment
Enlightenment entails seeing into one's
true nature the true nature reality
beyond what we perceive with just our
thoughts and physical senses beyond the
physical world beyond what we
conventionally think of as Humanity
Gojo's famous quote throughout Heaven
and Earth I alone am the honored one
isn't even Gojo's quote according to the
Zen Buddhist tradition this is a quote
attributed directly to the Buddha
himself obviously Buddhism is known for
the pursuit of an evolved Consciousness
for things like reincarnation and
rebirth and if Gojo has been so strongly
linked to Buddhism from the beginning
maybe this was all foreshadowing his
coming Evolution Beyond Humanity perhaps
this Evolution will be something similar
to master Tangen or perhaps it will be
very different this is probably my
preferred scenario for what happens next
because Gojo's Evolution would go hand
in hand with what kenja who is
essentially trying to do with the
culling game so it would make sense
thematically and it would also mean that
Gojo didn't just freaking die off screen
I I just can't get over that I'm sorry
now let me know what you guys think
right now down in the comments is Gojo
just straight up dead and he's not
coming back or is he going to unlock a
new power and somehow heal himself and
survive or is his body going to die
physically but his soul will somehow
survive inside of Yuji or somewhere else
or is he going to evolve Beyond Humanity
itself like tengen was Gojo's Evolution
Beyond Humanity all a part of kenjaku's
master plan if you want to know all the
details about kendricku's plan and his
secret connection to yuji's Mother check
out my video that breaks all of that
down for you in one place link on screen
and in the description if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more jjk
content here on the channel leave a
quick like right now and if you want to
help us become a special great anime
channel by hitting 2 million subscribers
Please Subscribe right now subscribing
on YouTube is completely free and it
helps me out a lot